oh i wanted to see what he does against
uh
e42 probably c5
like c3 should be five
[Music]
oh so this line okay and what if um
what if knight f3 here okay g6
oh he okay he could potentially fall
into this trap
e6 is a bad move because uh knight b5
so maybe i'll try and trap him with this
it's not the most likely but um
all right let's uh let's send a
challenge
let's play um oh let's play e4 i'm going
to try this trappy line
let's go yeah so expecting this and this
yeah okay so this is another part of
preparation
um oh he could play bishop g7 i think
he's actually more likely to play bishop
g7
but i'm hoping for this move because
then he'd be capable of
walking into a nice trap oh thanks for
that off the schnied
yeah so now bishop g7 takes takes here
and then e6
this is what i looked up before it's not
a good line for
for black the only good move here i
believe is knight h6
which i'll be surprised if he knows
yeah wow so this is this is why opening
prep pays off
so again it's a question if i can
convert
um but yeah it's already like difficult
for black because uh
this square is so weak uh no offense to
the square
queen b6 so queen b6 prevents knight d6
but and the usual idea is to play this
move
i'm calculating bishop f8 queen d3
even queen g3 wait a minute
queen g3 might be better here because i
have the additional threat of knight
c7 along with knight d6
of the square lol yeah
i don't want to offend anyone or any
squares
yeah okay i know it's good for white i
just have to figure out
figure out the best continuation um
because both moves look attractive i
think i'll go for this first
um expecting e5 and then queen a3
it's cool that the queen it has like so
many squares on the third rank to
access oh thanks everyone for subbing
yeah uh especially d6
and c7
thank you no free tacos and the almighty
dada subbing
both for two months appreciate that
yeah so still threatening this and the
problem with black playing e5 is uh
now the bishop has a target on f7
so with bishop f8 i can keep initiative
with a move like this or this
i was calculating this knight h6 and
then d3
i don't know we didn't really
predetermine we're just trying to play
like
friendly but competitive games so maybe
i'll message him after this game
yeah i'm thinking queen queen's a b3
here
and this looks really difficult for
black
because now d3
i'm threatening to take the knight so
basically threatening this and then
takes here
yeah i didn't even sack a pawn for this
and we still
each all have our uh our eight pawns
oh that's a move
so there's no like discovery tactics
uh this so these moves
none of them quite work so let's go for
this and then with a pawn
wait a minute to be careful
yeah otherwise i guess i'd taken play
983 and just
i'm up a pawn
queen
[Music]
i'm looking for other other options here
there's this crazy move
i don't think it works though
so knight a3
okay so all that for winning upon
um maybe black has compensation
um probably should maneuver the knight
back
yeah i go for a4
it was a very typical break with like
the structure on the queen side
i want to get the rook involved i like
to create some weakness in black's pawns
and he wants to play bishop e6
which
i probably should still go for this
[Music]
actually let's be solid let's develop
first
ah i'm not sure what to do here i just
have to move quickly
like this and then this and then this
i spent too much time trying to
to punish his opening
oh good move
oh this is really uncomfortable ah
don't flag me
no there goes my exchange
i didn't see what else to do oh
robocalls
[Music]
ah my pawn c4 maybe
i just i'm trying to get initiative
somehow
i guess you can just take cause i'm
pinned
play b4 i'm trying to complicate things
i mean this bishop is actually kind of
aesthetic
and if i can take i'm controlling the
queening square
also calculating takes takes takes and
then here
oh but then he mates me
or just defense
i'm living on the increment now
it's not the idea of this and this
no i be pawn
there goes my hope i have this move
this is my one last try
[Music]
uh-oh uh-oh
i got mated i spent too much time he
fought back well
good game so what do you think was the
only best game on the
so i i was proud of my preparation like
the preparation
i of course the staff of gambit prep i'm
proud of but the other one
that i kind of predicted beforehand was
a sicilian game
which one uh well i caught you in like
some opening trap
yeah wait wait you still won
so yes this one well this was
so interesting because i feel like i was
better
after i lose the pawn oh yeah
it was interesting yeah i know i'm
supposed to be better because
like e6 is not a good move for black
queen f4 was uh regime ray robson is
suggesting queen f4
instead of queen g3 but i don't know
preventing e5 oh that move was not a
consideration
because i like at first i thought okay
queen a3 is like the main idea then i
knew queen g3 is a resource
i forgot this has some perfect 15 months
of awesomeness
okay that looks pretty pretty annoying
um do i have to give up the exchange i
guess maybe play
king 7 you have to do something really
ugly
i think i have to play guinea's own
right i don't see anything else
yeah probably cloud against your world
stop that
yeah whenever you play e5 you lose f7
yeah that's what i did it for and it
doesn't work so that's not a choice then
what else though
maybe so so the thing about this line
you shouldn't play e6
i have to play knight h6 right so 96 is
all like probably the the best move yeah
that's what i knew and i said it oh wow
let's just play
six let's just face it it's funny i i
said it too but
um i found one game that you had played
like just going through your your games
and opening tree where you had played
this
so i did oh my god yeah some random game
on lee chess
wait this is an amazing way of preparing
guys if you know the username of someone
on on chess.com on leachat this isn't
this is crazy
because even i didn't remember that i
play e6
yeah it was the last thing i prepared
right before we we played
um oh you actually had two games in this
line
so look what i did e6 because i was like
oh let me get out of the opening
that's why i did it i did it because i
wanted to get out of the opening then
you play
right then i should have played knight
x6 because e6 is horrible
and no wonder why but you get all the
initiative with knight b5 i did not
think about knight b5 that's
crazy yeah you actually had this
position in a bullet game at the end of
august uh
and you did you lose
wow uh yeah you lost
who was that who was the player it was
probably some gm uh it was an i am uh
from norway wow yeah i remember playing
him oh wow e6
yeah yeah it was after uh after e6
knight b5
you had another game in your opponent
played 92 so it didn't punish you as
much
wow so it's almost like you just you
just knew yeah i'm gonna play six for
sure wow so
this line has or did you just sew it and
so usually what i'll do is if if i know
i'm going to be playing someone i'll
scout out like their
their repertoire and see what what
openings they'll be most likely to fall
into traps
and i'll just go through my like my e4
repertoire my london repertoire and see
like where they're vulnerable wow
so it's a nice uh it's a nice tool this
looks very this looks very dangerous
even after knight six because can i just
play the same knight v5 on pg3 i know it
doesn't look as strong anymore but
can i do it like wait say that one more
time
so like let's say if i go knight h6
oh no no no no i get it now because now
knight b5 doesn't work very well
because um because the bishop's not
blocked and
there's no d6 square yeah so
i i would play knight uh 92 and
then there's actually a cool idea for
black if i
cast or okay you castle and then if i
castle or even if i played d3 yes
there's an id4 move right
yeah so knight g4 taking advantage of
the fact if i take you have d5
and you want to play 95. i have a memory
of an anon game on this line but i don't
know if i'm right it's
some long time ago uh yeah there was a
phase where a lot of like strong players
were playing this there was a
mirosovich game spritzler played this
um so if you were to castle i would play
bishop b3 just preventing that g4
that makes sense because this is a huge
you know huge improvement for the nano
exactly i want to love that it's still
playable
but uh requires some knowledge of theory
can you see the arrows when i i put the
arrows too yes
yeah no it's everything synced up so
it's great yeah that's so cool you know
it's so it's so good for teaching i
don't know if you're still like
uh teaching these days but uh yeah i am
i don't i usually use chess bass um
never usually chess really for teaching
oh yeah but
yeah it's a bit more accessible i mean
both both programs work but
uh this has like the main features you
would need
uh that chef space has also make moves
that's yeah that's one
downside of chess base you are the only
one who can make moves
right yeah and you have control over uh
if like
your student can access engine or can
access opening book
um and everything's saved too so
yeah so so anyway after after knight b5
when
when after all this crazy stuff i feel
like after
after you trade queens i might be better
for real because i got the
bishop prayers and i was talking about
it i got into this by four years with
some
feel like i'm actually better and that's
what i felt i don't know
after b5 i don't see why i'm worse i
mean i mean
i think it took me it took me several
more moves to realize i'm i'm like
struggling
uh because i felt like all the momentum
was going my way it was a nice opening
i'm up a pawn
and then i realized oh you have a c file
i can never play rook c1
my knight is terrible i can't play f4
even
so one exactly you cannot what are you
gonna do with the nine
um yeah my my first instinct was to play
d6 on bishop e6
right to get rid of the c2
uh we you know defender but then i'm
like why why would i trade the pair of
bishops that make some sense
so yeah i was expecting bishop e6 and
then like you didn't play it
maybe this was a moment for you to play
something like a4
i i felt like you had to do it for
before i played five four because then
i was considering playing a4 even here
exactly like right now
maybe bishop d7 and then you take me or
just leave it there right but then if
you take your
you might be worse anyway so i was more
scared of bishop e6 maybe bishop d7 is
playable but this is also
v6 doesn't look very bad for you because
then you just take trade bishops on your
king
i thought my c pawn's still weak oh but
i have king d1
on it's good point you probably have
rouge two i mean i know it looks weird
but
is it because if now anytime i take here
you can actually go 92 maybe a nice
and then knight c4 right yeah that's a
good point
yeah i guess i control when the a file
opens that's why i didn't play bishop e6
at any point i was not gonna play i was
just gonna play bishop descent and
and i was hoping you were not gonna play
rook b and you i was hoping you would
allow me to play with ba
because then i stopped you from a4
because the b2b
is hanging that's that was a pretty big
yeah i like this b3 id like b3 just
like limits all your counter play
because it cuts off any play on the b
file defense c2
but my time was so bad i spent all this
time in the opening trying to
punish you more oh man yeah no i
a lot of the time in those games i
realized that you were low in time
almost at the end i didn't even i was
like okay
um when i looked i was like oh are you
down to 20 seconds all right
it's one of my biggest weaknesses
especially with three plus two
because i get too comfortable with the
increments you're right you're
yeah yeah yeah i played very fast uh
you know the last time so you've beaten
me on like chess.com
and stuff yeah or like oh you went on
the
one of the i think we placed we played
in us open actually
we played in us open if you remember
that blitz tournament
us open yeah it was in um
what state was it in
wait we did wait i forget what state
though
oh it's in orlando i think orlando well
i played two in orlando
i'm guessing what's the the longest one
the oldest one
it was a more recent one in orlando 2019
yeah august 2019 so last year i played
that one
because i i went to i went there not to
play in the main event but to do
commentary
but then i played in the blitz
tournament wait what was the line that
we played
so i actually i have the game saved on
me chats
okay okay please show it at all you beat
me right
so we well it was a double round uh i
beat you
in this like london pierce variation and
then you beat me
you played like f4 on move one and then
you beat me i remember now i remember
now because i lost that game
i feel like i was winning on that game
somehow in the first you know one that i
lost right
i don't know i remember it i have a
memory but not exactly sure
oh yeah us open blitz here this is the
last play us open
so not so long ago i i can invite you to
the
this new study yeah
like we can have a a little flashback
um right i i actually mentioned it
so the last game we we played just now
in this uh like you play g6 and then d5
yes they're the london oh my god yeah oh
i remember now this game yeah no no this
game you just completely crashed me
right
this game yeah like you you just walked
into this king side attack oh yeah oh i
you just completely destroy me
and then i didn't even know why i played
d6 i
it's just one of those moves that you do
sometimes you don't even know why uh-huh
i i i don't play this line i always play
d5
so i play d6 and i'm like why did i get
them through this
why in the world and that's somehow
almost two
yeah but no you were trying to survive
but
unfortunately things just just kind of
fell apart was a i thought maybe i could
survive here but no 27
right actually missed 27 that's also
what happened too i didn't even see
quinnish
ah yeah of course but you know it
doesn't matter
my position even if if you have to go
back maybe i can play a four or
something i don't know but queen takes
c7 is just
it's funny how like you you play a blitz
game a couple years ago and then you
then you
you remember it just now and it brings
back some uh some painful memory
it's like they're hidden in the back of
your of your head you know
right hands back to you it's like whoa
well yes now i remember everything now i
don't remember the one that i
i won it was some bird opening
i i don't think i even put it it was a
longer game the reason i put this game
in because it was very short
you don't want to show that i beat you
that's fine maybe that too
never mind but like i i use this game
from time to time as like a model game
for students just to show how to play
the structure
it was going so nice
but sometimes i'll show my losses too is
like just just to offer some inspiration
like these these quick games can be
installed only winning only winning
first year
that's better